شكرا جلال معركه حاميه الوطيس تدور منذ
الليله الماضيه في خان يونس سنركز عليها
في هذه النافذه التحليليه
لمجريات الميدانيه في حرب اسرائيل على
قطاع غزه والتي نستضيف فيها اللواء فايز
الدويري لكن نبدا بتطورات المشهد الميداني
عبر الخريطه التفاعليه مع محمود الكان
محمود نعم زين العابدين نحن سنشاهد
مناورات مختلفه خلال هذه المرحله يقوم بها
جيش الاحتمال الاحتلال على كامل قطاع غزه
هذه المناورات تتشكل حسب هذه الصوره اذا
ما شاهدناها هذا هو اللون الاصفر وما نقصد
به بالمناورات هي امكانيه التوغل التراجع
العوده لكن نقاط الارتكاز لجيش الاحتلال
سنشاهدها على كامل الشريط الشرقي هنا هذه
المناطق وبحسب المصادر المفتوحه وب حسب
المصادر على الارض
يتمركز هنا ق قوات الاحتلال وتحاول الدخول
باتجاه الغرب في كامل انحاء القطاع باي
انها تقوم بعمليه الدفع بهذه الطريقه هنا
في هذه المناطق تحاول الدفع ايضا كذلك من
اتجاه الشمالي تحاول الدفع في المنطقه
الوسطى عبر هذه المناطق وهذا هو محور صلاح
الدين على كامل القطاع بهذه بهذا الخط
بالتالي محور صلاح الدين هو نقطه تفصل
الشرق عن الغرب وتقوم قوات الاحتلال
بمحاوله السيطره الناريه الكامله عليه
مركز ثقل العمليات هو هنا في خانيونس
في المنطقه الجنوبيه طبعا هذا في السابق
كانت التوغ هي بشكل اكبر في الكتله او في
الجهه الشماليه من القطاع لكن الان الوضع
مختلف اذا ما نظرنا الى خ خانيونس
هنا في خانيونس نشاهد هذا اللون الاصفر
لمحاولات المناوره الاسرائيليه هي تحاول
كانت التوغل احيانا كانت تتقدم من كيسوفيم
سابقا باتجاه الجنوب وتعبر باتجاه الغرب
ثم تتجه باتجاه الجنوب بهذه الطريقه ثم
عادت الى المطاحن لكن تراجعت اللافت هنا
ان قوات سواء قوات المشاء الم راعات
والمظليين تحاول الالتفاف من هذه النقاط
ايضا من الجانب الجنوبي هنا سنشاهد محور
صلاح الدين مره اخرى نعيد الحديث عنه دوما
وهو قوات الاحتلال تحاول مناوره بهذا
الاتجاه لتلتقي بشكل ما يشبه فك الكماشه
في هذه المناطق لكن ليس حصارا باعتبار ان
هذه المناطق ما تزال مفتوحه ايضا انسحبت
وانكفا هذه قوات الاحتلال الى هذه المناطق
هنا حيث
سنشاهد باتجاه عبسان عبسان الجديده كانت
قد انكف انكف سابقا الى الشريط السياج
الحدودي مع قوات الاحتلال هذه المناورات
لها هذا الشكل لا يتم عبر لواء لوائين او
ثلاثه انما نتحدث عن سبع الى ثمانيه الويه
في نقطه في النقطه هنا كيف تتوزع هذه
الالويه سنشاهد هذه
الخريطه هذه الخريطه تمثل الالويه
الاسرائيليه التي تعمل الان في قطاع غزه
دعونا نشاهد هنا تقسم الى ثلاث مناطق
عمليات رئيسيه الشمال الوسط والجنوب
الجنوب هو مركز ثقل العمليات
الان الالويه الاسرائيليه السبعه او
الثمانيه هذه بحسب المعهد الاستراتيجي
لمعهد دراسات الحروب تتكون من ثلاثه الويه
مدرعه من
لوائي مشا من لوائي مظليين اضافه الى لواء
للعمليات الخاصه هي تعمل في كام في منطقه
او في القطاع الجنوبي للعمليات في خان
يونس في المناطق الوسطى هنا حيث البريج
مخيم
النصيرات هنا ثلاثه الويه التشكيلات تتم
حسب لواء مظليين لواء مدرعات وايضا لواء
مش
في الشمال تتكون من ثلاث ثلاثه الويه
وكتيبه واحده وهنا تقوم بعمليات تكتيكيه
مختلفه هذه الالويه تتشكل من المشاد تتشكل
من المدرعات ولواء مشات ومنها نحال اضافه
الى لواء المشات وكتيبه اضافيه كانت
موجوده في اللواء الجنوبي جفعاتي تنتقل
الى الشمال اذا نلاحظ من هذا هذا التوزيع
شكلا لمركز ثقه عمليات عسكريه كيف تركز
قوات الاحتلال جهودها الحربيه في الجنوب
بثقل يوازي بل واكبر من عدد الاليات
والاليه الموجوده مجتمعه في الوسط والشمال
لكن لماذا هذا التشكيل كيف تعمل كل هذه
الالويه مع بعضها وهنا وكيف ترد قتا بال
المقاومه التي تستمر حتى الان في
استهدافها واعلنت عن استهدافها وسقوط عدد
ثلاثه ضباط من في مختلف انحاء المعارك حيث
اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي ذلك سقوط ثلاثه
ضبات واصابه اخرين اضافه الى استهداف
بقذائف الياسين والتان دوم وغيرها ما تزال
كل هذه القوات تواجه صعوبه شديده وكيف
تعمل كل هذه العمليات بالحذر المزيد معكما
زين العابدين واللواء فايز دويري شكرا
محمود وهذا بالتحديد ما نريد ان نعرفه
ايضا ويعرفه مشاهدون هذه معركه كبيره
تابعنا جزء منها على الهواء بالامس مع
مراسلين واليوم ايضا معركه شديده حميه
الوطيس ب القصف بالاشتباكات في خانيونس
نتحدث عن ثمانيه الويه في مساحه جغرافيه
ضيقه نريد ان نعرف اولا ما هي مقاربه
ال القوات المهاجمه
في مثل هذه المعركه سيدي اولا لو نظرنا
الى الخارطه ويعطينا محمود الخارطه
الملونه ل هناك بعض الامور لابد من
توضيحها ومن ثم نجيب على السؤال حتى تكون
هناك توطئه للاجابه على
السؤال طبعا الخارطه الان اللي بنظر
لها في القاطع الشمالي بناء على اللون
الاصفر يعتبر ان هناك ما يقارب نصف
المنطقه
الشماليه دخلتها قوات العدو لا هذه تمثل
تحركات القوات
وليس الدخول لانه التمركز كما قال محمود
هو على الان اذا نظرنا اذا نظرنا الى
الزاويه
الشماليه
الغربيه
وصرنا مع شارع الرشيد الى ما بعد كلمه غزه
الى ما بعد الميناء الى منطقه الشاليهات
بالامس صور الاقمار الصناعيه كان مجموع
القوات الموجود فيها تقريبا 20 اليه اذا
نحن نتحدث عن قوات محدوده اذا ذهبنا الى
الشيخ رضوان موجود بعض الاليات واقول بعض
الاليات مع قناصين ام اذا ذهبنا للمنطقه
الشماليه بيت حانون بيت
لاهيه تواجد القوات الرئيسيه اصلا خارج
القطاع وفي الغلاف على عمق خمسه الى 15 م
وتدفع بقوات بين الحين والاخر التواجد
الرئيسي
في منطقه التفاح الدرج جبل الريس
جباليا مجموع القوات في جبل الريس التفاح
والدرج كتيبه مشاه كتيبه دروع مسرده بكتبه
مشاه بسريه مدفعيه
بهندسه مقاتله اللي هي الجارفه ناين التي
وبقيه القوات في الخارج والان في منطقه
جباليه القوه غير معروفه بهذا الحجم بقيه
القوه في الخارج اذا الخارطه الصفراء هي
تمثل مناطق حركه قوات العدو وليس تواجده
اه وهذا يحقق سيطره امنيه ام لا يحقق هذا
لا يحقق بالمطلق وهذا مطلب
المقاومه اذا عدنا عشره ايام للوراء
الخارطه اللون الاصفر من المنطقه الشماليه
كان شبه منتهي متلاشي لكن كانت حاله
الاشتباك قائمه هناك قصف مدفعي قصف صاروخي
طائرات الاباتشي طائرات كوات
كابتور طائرات الدرون الصغيره وبالتالي
هناك ضربات متتاليه
و المقاومه لا تستطيع ان تشتبك لانه
اسلحتها لا ت يعني تتمكن من خلال القصف
الصاروخي واستخدام الهاون لكن ان يكون
القتال مؤثر وفاتوره التكاليف عاليه يجب
ان يكون القتال من المساف في الصفريه
وبالتالي سمعنا وقرانا وتابعنا بدات عناصر
القسام تظهر فوق الارض وتتحرك على شكل
الذئاب المنفرده من خلال الحركه والمناوره
وهنا بدا العدو يدخل من اجل التعامل مع
الظاهره الجديده سبق ذلك ان هذه المنطقه
يوجد فيها لوائين لواء غزه ولواء الشمال
بمجموع ثمانيه كتائب يختلف احجامها من 800
الى 1250 اعادوا تموضع الدفاعي
واعادوا صياغه مقاربتهم القتاليه وبالتالي
عندما دخل الى التفاح والى الريس والى
اطراف جباليه هذا كان انا من بعد تحليلي
هو مطلب مطلب المقاومه حتى يكون
هناك رد فعل مقابل الفعل والا ستكون
معادله خاسره هذا فيما يتعلق في منطقه
الشمال بحج هذا الذي شبال وذكرته هذه
المقاربه يعني واضح الان ان المقاومه
لديها مقاربه وان جيش الاحتلال لديه
مقاربه نعم هل هل هذا هو المستقبل في
خانيونس ام حتى هذه اللحظه علينا علينا
ننتقل الان الى منطقه خان يونس تمام الان
خان يونس الاصل في اداره
المعارك ان الجهد الثانوي يوظف لخدمه
الجهد الرئيسي ما يجري الان لا هو عكس عكس
المقاربه
بالمطلق الجهد الرئيسي يوظف لانجاح الجهد
الثانوي قد تبدو المقاربه غريبه قد تبدو
محل ستكون محل نقاش من المحللين وهي تحتاج
الى شرح نعم ساشرحها يعني لا س بعض
المحللين سيقول ماذا ماذا يتحدث اقول حتى
هذه المنطقه الصفراء المضلله هي لا تمثل
انتشار هي تمثل حركه قوات تمام لماذا لانه
هو انسحب من القرار وانسحب من الزنه
وانكفى الى
كفيم هذه المنطقه انسحب منها ولا يوجد له
تواجد حتى ما قبل 48 ساعه قبل 48 ساعه
اعاد القوه لماذا من اجل الهجوم الثانوي
الذي ساتحدث عنه اضافه الى الهجوم القادم
من منطقه جوش قطيف ودخل خان يونس من
المنطقه الغربيه ماذا جرى خلال الايام
الماضيه تم فت فتح الجبهه الشرقيه بالكامل
من القراره الى الزنه الى عبسان الى بني
سهيله الى عبسان الى خزاعه الى الفاخوري ا
هذه الجبهه مشتعله بالمطلق تمام عندما
تشتعل هذه الجبهه القراءه المبدئيه للمخطط
ان القوات المدافعه في ظل تباين القوه
ونوعيه القوه وتسليح
القوه يتوقع ان هناك لواء غزه يتالف من
كتائب ان القوات المتواجده في غرب صلاح
الدين تدافع عن غزه ستجبر على الحركه
لمناصرته القوات التي تواجه هذا الخط
الطويل نحن نقول طويل طويل بالنسبه
ل تقريبا 16 م احن نقول عنها مساحه كبيره
قياسا مع الخانق ل 6 ك مت والا هي هي كل
المنطقه اقل من واجهه فرقه بثلاثه الويه
وليس بثمان الويه اذا كانت القراءه ان من
يدافع عن مدينه خان يونس سيتم الاحتفاظ
بالقوات القادره على ادا تثبيت خطوط
الاشتباك في ثلاثه نقاط في منطقه السجن
والمحطه والكتيبه ام منطقه شارع خمسه
وشارع السكه تمام وبالتالي وبالتالي بدا
الضغط الان ماذا جرى تم تفعيل الذراع البع
لكن ه هو نجح اولا يعني هو حاول ان يست
يستدرج قوات الى الجبهه الشرقيه نعم هذا
لم ذ هذا لم يحدث هذا لم يحدث هذه مقاربه
الاسرائيليه ن المقاربه الاسرائيليه هكذا
لكن مقاربه كما اقرا من خلال المعركه ان
القوه التي كانت موكله بالدفاع عن غزه
بقيت في غزه ولم تتح تذهب باتجاه
الخداع لنعد الى قبل بدايه الحمل البريه
كان هناك عمليه توغل وعمليه التوغل دخلت ل
مئات الامتار
ولم يتم التعامل معها
بالمطلق وقالت القسام في تلك الفتره كنا
نعلم انها وكانت في خان يونس ايضا نعم
وكان كانت في خانيونس تم التعامل معها بس
في بيت حانون وبيتها لم يتم التعامل معها
والناس استغربت وانا حتى في نفس اليوم قلت
من يدير المعركه الدفاعيه اعلم بشؤونه
لماذا هنا تدخل وهناك لم يتدخل لانه كانت
قراءته انها عمليه خداع ام الان هذ عم هذا
الخداع نفسه هذا الخداع
نفسه لم يمر على المقاومه اذا لو لو انطلت
الخدعه
على لو انطلت الخدعه على المقاتلين لكان
النجاح يحسب للجهد الثانوي الذي تم دفعه
من القراره باتجاه غرب الزنه باتجاه خان
يونس ومن منطقه جوش قطيف لكن لاحظ شده
القتال اليوم في خان يونس ماذا يعني يعني
ان هذه الخدعه لم تنطلي على المدافع وبقيت
القوات المعينه للدفاع عن خان يونس القوات
في المنطقه الشرقيه قادره على الصد تمام
ولم تحتاج الى مساعده
تحرك انا هكذا اقرا اه وبالتالي تحرك من
هذه المناوره الى مناوره اخرى وهي الدخول
من الشمال الشرقي والجنوب الشرقي وتابع
ذلك لكن دع ننوه فقط الى هذا الخبر العاجل
الجيش الاسرائيلي يقول تم نقل 15 جنديا
وضابطا اصيبوا بجروح مختلفه في معارك خان
يونس طبعا هو اعلن عن بالفعل مقتل ثلاثه
ضباط في هذه المعارك الان يتح 15 جنديا
وضابطا اصيبوا بجروح في هذه المعارك ما
الذي يجري
الان الان بقيت نقطه واحده انت تحدثت عن
ومحمود تحدث عن عمليه الالتفاف من الجنوب
نعم هذه حدثت متى قبل اكثر من ع ايام ليس
الان واستطاعت ان تدخل من جنوب خزاعه ما
بين خزاعه
والفخاريات الحركت في المنطقه السهليه ما
بين خان يونس
ورفح انعطفت باتجاه قيزان
النجار واستطاعت ان تعبر من منطقه قيزان
النجار وتعمل تماس مع البوليتكنيك اوكي
ماذا
جرى القوه المدافعه عن قازان النجار اجبرت
العدو على التراجع التراجع وبقيت القوه
التي في تماس مع البوليتكنيك الان يسعى
لاعاده تكثيف الهجوم وتعزيز هذا الهجوم
لعله يحقق الاحاطه التي اشار لها محمود
قبل قليل حتى هذه اللحظه لا اقول ان
المقاومه حسمت المعركه لصالحها ولا اقول
ان قوات جيش الاحتلال حسمت المعركه الان
مشتعله في قمه الاداء الميداني وعلينا ان
ننتظر الساعات القادمه حتى ينقشع غبار
المعركه طيب ننوه ايضا الى هذا الخبر
العاجل كتاب القسام تقول اوقع افراد قوه
صهيونيه خاصه بين قتيل وجريح بقذيفه تي بي
جي في مبنى تحصنت به جنوب غرب غزه يعني
هذا غزه هذا ما تحدثت عنه قبل قليل عندما
قلت لك القوات القادمه من جوش قطيف هي
التي دخلت وهي التي تحاول و هذه فقط
للتذكير قبل ثلاثه ايام تم انزال جوي
بمعدل 16 طن من المواد الدفاعيه واللوازم
والاغذيه لايصالها لهذه القوات لان هذه
القوات لا اقول انها كانت محاصره لكنها
كانت عاجزه عن تامين وصول الامدادات طيب
ما الذي يسعى جيش الاحتلال لتحقيقه الان
بهذه المعركه التي تدور حاليا في خانيونس
وما هي مقاربه المقاومه هل هي مقاربه
منع التوغل ام الاستفاده من التوغل لاحداث
اكبر قدر ممكن من الخسائر وجعل البقاء مست
تخو معركه من بعدين
اه هي تحاول منع التقدم ولكن تخذ معركه في
العمق من المسافه الصفريه فبالتالي هي
تحقق كلا الغايتين في نفس المعركه المعركه
ليست معركه صد لوحدها انما هي معركه صد
لانه الصد كد يكون مستحيل لانك كما تفضلت
اليه لكل مقا لا يمكن لا يمكن الان يوجد
ثمانيه الويه في هذه المنطقه ماذا يعني
ثمانيه الويه الفرقه ثلاثه الويه يوجد
ثلاثه فرق ناقص لانه لو كان هناك لواء
تاسع لقلنا ثلاثه فرق وهذه الفرق مجمعه
لاغراض العمليات تحت قياده الفرقه 98 يعني
الان الذي يدير المعركه قائد واحد هو قائد
الفرقه 98 هو الذي يدير معركه الثمانيه
الويه وبالتالي الان لو لو لو احصنا اعداد
الاليات كامله المقاتله وغير المقاتله
ستكون بالالاف بالالاف وبالتالي كما قلت
يعني مجازا قد يكون بعض الحالات كل مقاتل
يخرج من النفق
سيكون نصيبه اليه واذا اخذنا الاعداد
البشريه للمقارنه قد تكون واحد قد اقول قد
تكون واحد لعش نريد ان نضع ايدينا على
مفاتيح النجاح في مثل هذه المعركه هي طبعا
لابد من الاشاره الى اننا لا نتحدث عن
معركه متناظره ولا متكافئه جيش بكل العتاد
بكل الامداد وا مقاتلين محصورون في
الانفاق منذ اشهر و محاصرون في الواقع ف
فيما يتعلق ب مقاييس النجاح والفشل في هذه
المكه سدي اولا مقاييس النجاح بالنسبه
للحرب غير المتناظره القاعده العامه التي
انا اؤمن بها وتحدثت بها كثيرا وقد اكون
اول ما تحدث
بها الضعيف اذا لم يهزم فهو منتصر والقوي
اذا لم ينتصر فهو مهزوم الان ناتي ما هي
الاهداف التي يسعى لتحقيقها على الاقل
الاهداف المعلنه اليست الاهداف المعلنه
تتمثل بالقضاء على حماس ولنقل الذراع
العسكري لحماس لنقل الذراع العسكري لحماس
هذا الهدف الاول الذي يتح حدث عنه نتنياهو
يوميا والهدف الثاني اطلاق سراح الرهائن
والقضاء بصوره جزئيه يعني اذا اخذنا الهدف
الاول القضاء على على الذراع العسكري
لحماس على الاقل القضاء على نخبه الصف
الاول محمد ضيف وابو عبيده
والسنوار اذا الان اذا استطاع ان يحقق بعض
هذه الاهداف سيتحدث كما تحدث اوباما عندما
قتل بن لادن وقال انجاز اذا الان سيقول
انجزنا لكن هذا الهدف لم يتحقق لا هم
وصلوا الى قاده الصف الاول السياسي او
العسكري في الداخل ولا وصلوا الى الرهائن
ولا استطاعوا ان يقلم او اظافر القوه
القتاليه لحماس المعركه مستمره الان انت
سالت من يستطيع تحمل ما يجري هذا الامر
يعتمد على فاتوره التكاليف اذا كانت وتور
التكاليف تميل لصالح حماس س سينسحب منها
كما ان سحب من غزه اذا كان العكس سيتابع
انجازاته ولكنني اميل الى ان حماس لديها
القدره على اداره المعركه بنجاح وستكون
فاتوره التكاليف باهظه وسيجبر على التوقف
طيب في هذه الحاله يعني مساله اهداف الحرب
طبعا هذه فيديوهات لجيش الاحتلال وربما لم
نضعها من البدايه لانه ربما لا توفر
الكثير من المعلومات التي يمكن تحليلها
لانه نفس ال نعتبرها فتره راحه نعتبرها
فتره راحه ننظر لها لانه لا تحتاج الى
تحليل نفس التحليل اللي حكيناه في الا
اليوم الاول يمثل طرف من
المعادله لدينا خبر عاجل ايضا موقع ول
الاسرائيلي يقول اليوم هو اصعب ايام
القتال في قطاع غزه منذ بدايه الحرب وهذا
ما قلنا في بدايه النافذه نحن نتحدث عن
معركه كبيره في خانيونس موقع و الان يقول
معركه معركه يعني اشرس المعارك واصعب ايام
القتال من هل يجوز لي ان ان اطلق عليها
معركه كسر العظم هذه معركه كسر العظم ام
من يكسر عظم الثاني اولا هو من سيربح
المعادله ا هذه معركه كسر العظم ان تحشد
هذا الكم الهائل من القوه في مساحه
جغرافيه لا تتعدى 16 في في 10 م 160 م
مربع هذه ساحه يعني اذا عدنا للحرب
العالميه الثانيه فرقه الشبح التي كان
يقودها رومل في فرنسا المساحه الجغرافيه
اليوميه لها تعادل اضعاف مساحه قطاع غزه
لمن لا يلا هم الضباط الذين قتلوا اليوم
واعلن عنهم جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي هذه
معركه كبيره ما هي مقاربه المقاومه في مثل
هذه المعركه امام هذا الحشد الذي لم يتوفر
حتى في معركه غزه ولا معارك الشمال هذا
حشد غير مسبوق للقوات الاسرائيليه في كامل
معاركه في قطاع غزه ما هي الخيارات
المتاحه للمقاومه حتى اجيبك انا اطرح
تساؤل وساجي الخيارات المطروحه هو خياره
نوه س الواء الى هذا الخبر العاجل ايضا
كتاب القسام تقول اوقعنا افراد قوه
صهيونيه خاصه بين قتيل وجريح بقذيفه تي بي
جي في مبنى تحصنت به بجنوب غرب غزه تقول
ايضا تمكنا من قنص جندي صهيوني واصابته
اصابه مباشره جنوب غرب مدينه غزه وربما
هنالك دلالات نحن نتحدث عن خان يونس ولا
الاسرائليه موقع ولا الاسرائليه يتحدث عن
خري يونس اي المقاومه تتحدث عن معارك في
غزه في هذه اللحظه يا سيدي يعني انت ترات
في البدايه ما هي
الخيارات لا يوجد خيارات الا خيار واحد
خيار واحد فقط الاستمرار والقتال لانه ما
هو البديل رفع رايه الرا رايه الاستسلام
رايه الاستسلام لن لن ترفع لانه هذا من
يقاتل ويقاتل عن شرف عن شرفه وعرضه ودمه
ووطنه و لا بل ابعو ش يدافع عن كرامه
الامه وبالتالي لا يمكن ان يرفع رايه
الاستسلام وكان هناك مقوله لاحد الكتاب
الاسرائيليين قال مقاتلي حماس لو استطعت
ان ان تقطع ساقيه وتقطع احد ذراعيه وتقطع
ثلاثه اصابع من اليد المتبقيه سيرفع اشاره
النصر اذا اذا هذه هي الفلسفه الموجوده هو
احد المتطرفين ايضا مردخاي كدار لكن انت
تقول ان هذه هي المعركه ما يجري في خال
يونس الان
معكه كسر عظم هذه معركه غزه نعم هذه انا
تحدثت عندما بدات الحمله باتجاه خان يونس
قلت معارك خان يونس قد تنسينا روعه معارك
مدينه غزه انا قلت هذا الكلام في في اليوم
الاول من انطلاق المعركه الثانيه لماذا
لانه القناعه لدى الجانب الاسرائيلي ان
القاده موجودين في هذه المنطقه ولواء
ولواء خانيونس هو سجل حافل هو اول من
استخدم الشواظ البدائيه والصقها على
الدبابه هو اول من صعد على ظهر الدبابه
وهي متحركه وبالتالي هناك حقد دفين على
هذه المنطقه ولكن كما قلت لك هنا لانه
كثافه القوات وحجم القوات ولكن في النهايه
هذا الحجم من القوه تم توظيفه حول مدينه
غزه ا كانت هناك ثلاثه فرق من تسعه الويه
تقاتل في نفس الوقت وقت في غزه واستطاعت
المقاومه ان تصمد فكما صمدت في القاطع
الشمالي ستصمد في القاطع الجنوبي ام هذه
القوه الكبيره
ام بالنسبه للمقاومه فرصه ام عامل ضغط
كبير كلاه عليها كلاهما لا لا استطيع ان
اقول لا استطيع ان انكر انه عامل ضغط بسبب
حجم القوه لانه اي اي اي نصر تكتيكي مفاد
لاي جزء من هذه القوه قد يطور الى انجاز
عملياتي واستراتيجي ولكنه بالمقابل هو
يعطي الفرصه للمقاتل ان لان هناك وفره من
الاهداف وبالتالي اي خروج من المقاتل من
النفق قد يكون طيب لا هناك صيد بان هذه
معركه مختلفه ومعركه انت تقول انها مصيريه
هل مقاربه المقاومه في خانيونس مشابهه
لمقاربات في معارك الشمال والوسط لا اداره
المعركه مختلفه قد تكون متماثله في مدينه
غزه تقريبا 5 م م مربع هذه المنطقه قد
تكون متقاربه لماذا بسبب اكتظاظ المباني
وبسبب محدودي الانفا فتحات الانفاق ولكن
هذه المحدوديه تعطي افضليه حتى نسبيه بانه
مجرد ان يخرج يجد المكان الذي يختبئ به
لكن اذا ذهبنا الى شرط المنطقه لا المنطقه
سهليه المنطقه مفتوحه يوجد بها لا اقول
ساحات لكن يوجد بها مساحات لكن ماذا
يقابله تعدد في
فوهات الانفاق التي تسمح بظهور اعداد اكبر
مما ما هو مسموح به في مدينه غزه او في
مدينه خان يونس ما الذي يمكن ان يخرج به
جيش الاحتلال من هذه المعركه ويستطيع ان
يقول انه صوره
انتصار
يعني الان يعني لن اجيب على ناحيه
افتراضيه لانه اخشى ان يكون اجابتي غير
دقيقه ولكن اقول ان المعركه الحاليه علينا
ان ننتظر الساعات القادمه 24 42 ساعه
ستكون الاجابه على سؤالك اكثر وضوحا
وواقعيه وقربا من الحقيقه لكن هذه المعركه
الان هي معركه حاسمه
لانه الجيش الاسرائيلي يلقي بكل ثقله
الناري من حيث العدد القوات وبالمقابل
لواء غزه يعتبر اللواء لواء خانيونس يعتبر
احد اهم الالويه القتاليه ويضاف لذلك ان
لواء خان يونس يدعم قوات النخبه من سرايا
القدس وبقيه الفصائل بمعنى اخر تواجد
الفصائل الاخرى الرديفه للقسام تواجدها
الرئيسي في منطقه خان يونس واكبر بكثير من
تواجدهم في مدينه غزه حينما يقول الجيش
الاسرائيلي انه يحارب فوق الارض وتحت
الارض ما الذي يمكن فهمه من ذلك هو يحارب
فوق الارض بعد ظهور المقاتل من تحت الارض
لانه المقاتل اصلا مكانه تحت الارض وهو
يقاتل تحت الارض بالانفاق التي يعرضها
وبانه يعني يفعل كل جهده للوصول ال شبكه
الانفاق وهو يقاتل تحت الارض يعني هذه
تعبير مجازي هناك ثلاثه قتلوا باستخدام
الغازات السامه من قبل جيش الاحتلال في
الانفاق والذي فضحهم المستشفى الذي اجرى
عمليه تشريح الجثث وو والده احد القتلى
تحدثت صراحه بان ابنها قتل بسبب الغازات
التي استخدمها جيش الاحتلال وليس بسبب
القسام
ا طبعا هذه هي الالويه التي يتحدث عنها
محمود نحن نتحدث عن ثمانيه الويه منها ما
هو مدرع منها ما هو قوات خاصه منها ما هو
الويه مشاح لكن ما هي
النقاط نحن نتحدث عن معركه تحت الارض
الانفاق بالنسبه للمقاومه هي عصب الحياه
وهو اساس الخطه خطه
المقاومه ما هي النقاط التي سيقاتل فيها
مقاتل المقاومه حتى النهايه وما هي
الاهداف التي يمكن ان يترك لجيش الاحتلال
التوغل فيها يا سيدي الان الانفاق اعتقد
ان شب احنا يعني بدات استخدم مصطلح شبكات
الانفاق صحيح لانه يعني لو كانت شبكه
انفاق شبكه واحده عندما يتم اكتشاف نفق
كما شاهدنا بالامس قد يفضي النفق الى ما
بعده ولكن هناك سؤ يعني طرحت سؤالين وسعيد
طرح هذه الاسئله لانه يعني هي الزامي
اعادتها لحتى
اجيبك هذه الانفاق التي عرضت بالامس لو
كانت انفاق تفضي الى شبكه الانفاق
القتاليه وتقدم خدمه مستقبليه لجيش
الاحتلال لن يقوم ب بدعوه وسائل الميديا
للاطلاع عليها كان استثمرها لما هو بعد
ولو كانت تقدم له خدمه مستقبليه لما قام
بتدميرها ما دلاله ما هو تفسير ذلك تفسير
ذلك ان هناك شبكات من الانفاق شبكه انفاق
للقتال شبكه انفاق للابعاد الاداريه
واللوجستيه وال سكن والتصنيع والتخزين الى
غير ذلك وبالتالي هذه الانفاق لا تنفتح
على بعضها البعض بصوره واضحه جدا تفضي اذا
ولكن معظم الانفاق التي عرضت اعتقد انها
من من من خلال تشطيبات ما داخل النفق هذا
للحياه وليس لل وليس للقتال لانه شاهدنا
بعض انفاق القتال عندما كان الجندي
المقاتل الفلسطيني يظهر من ف فتحه نفق لا
تتعدى متر بمتر و ويصعد على على سلم من
الحديد او مواسير الحديد ويخرج ل مواجهه
الدبابه اذا هذا هذا لا يمكن ان يف ان
يكون نفق قتالي هذا نفق خدمي نفق خدمي ولا
يمكن ان يكون هذا النفق ينفتح بصوره واضحه
صريحه على شبكه الانفاق القتاليه هكذا
اقرا يعني وبالتالي حينما تحدثوا عن ان
مساله الهدف هدف القضاء على
المقاومه يعني في تقديرات قالوا واشهر
وتقديرات قالوا قالوا سنوات يعني ما ما هي
العوامل التي يبنى عليها هذا التقدير حتى
هذه اللحظه هي عمليه معلومات يعني هي
اي قراءات حتى ما صدر عن ويست بوينت هو
مجرد قراءات ان القسام لديه القدره على ان
يقاتل لثلاثه اشهر قادمه طبعا هذا الكلام
لا اعتقد انه يعني جاء من منظور تحليلي
بقدر ما هو استند الى تصريح سابق ان
المقاومه كان تصريح لاحد المسين واعتقد في
حرب 21 ان لديها القدره على القتال لمده
سته اشهر فافترقوا انه مر ثلاثه اشهر وبقي
ثلاثه اشهر فاعتقد ان حتى ما خرجت به ويست
بوينت هو استنادا الى تصريح سابق لاحد
قاده حماس بالنسبه لمعركه الانفاق انت
ذكرت نقطه مهمه وهي انها شبكات غير متصله
ببعضها البعض الضروره وطبعا نحن نتحدث
الان في اليوم ال 110 للحرب ف اصبح لدينا
بعض المعلومات وبعض الفكره عن هذه الانفاق
لكن كيف تدير المقاومه معركه
الانفاق يعني هل هذه هي الطريقه انها غير
متصله لا يؤدي بعضها الى بعض اكيد في
الحسبان ايضا مساله الاغراق بالمياه اكيد
في الحسبان مساله القنابل
السامه بحيث لو القيت قنبله سامه في في
نفق لا يسمى مش الشبكه كلها يعني واضح ان
هنالك يعني طريقه في اداره معركه الانفاق
يعني اولا حتى هذه اللحظه ما نجهله عن
الشبكه شبكات الانفاق ا اكثر من ما نعلم
وبالتالي نحن نتحدث على ما ما تم عرضه بعد
ما لم يعرض هو هو الجزء المهم هو يعني نحن
ننظر الى الجزء الفارغ من الكاس لانه
استنفذ واستهلك والان اصبح لا لا فائده
منه بينما الجزء المليء في الكاس لا يوجد
معلومات لا لدي ولا لدي الجيش الاسرائيلي
ولا لدى امريكا والاستخبارات الدول الخمسه
التي تتواجد في اكثر من مكان لايقاف هذا
العدو على على على ساقين من خشب
وبتالي معركه الانفاق ستبقى معركه تفاجئني
وتفاجئ وتفاجئ الجميع لكن اعتقد ان هناك
عند كانت كلمه ل الملثم عندما ق قال لا
يوجد
مستودعات وذهب البعض في تفسيرها بانها
خارج غذا في غز وبانها وبانها لا انا اقول
تحليلي لما ورد في
كلمته ان
المخزون القسام يقاتل وبقيه الفصائل على
النظام
العنقودي
هناك عقد ق العقد العقد والنظام العنقودي
الخلايا المقاتله وكل خليه مقاتله اخذت
مستلزمات معها وبالتالي اداره المعركه هي
خليط بين المركزيه
واللامركزيه
مركزيه الاداره تتعلق باطلاق الصواريخ في
العمق في
العمق لعمق فلسطين المحتله لامركزيه
القتال كذلك
متدرجه تبدا من قائد المجموعه قد يكون
لديه الصلاحيه بان يخرج احد افراده
للمراقبه وجلب المعلومه واتخاذ القرار
ولكن سيكون هناك بالتنسيق مع من هو اعلى
ويضاف الى ذلك ان اليه عملهم ال يه عملهم
بالنظام العنقودي لديهم خطوط اتصال في
مستويات معينه لكنها لا تفضح الكل بحيث
اذا ما القي القبض على احد
الخلايا ستكون قناه سهله للوصول الى
البقيه اعتقد ان حتى هذه اللحظه لم نرى
فيديوهات سوى فيديو المدارس التي
والمدنيين الذين تبين انهم مدنيون الذين
زعم جيش الاحتلال لانه القى القبض عليهم
لكن لم نشهد مثلا احدا يخرج من النفق
مستسلما او شيء من هذا طبيل يا سيدي يعني
ان نقول لم يتم الحاق الضرر بالقسام هذا
كلام عبثي لم نقول انهم لم يدمروا من
الانفاق كلام عبثي لم نقول انهم
اي استطاعوا ان يقتلوا واصبح هناك عدد
كبير من الشهداء هذا امر غير منطقي هل
تعلم انه تقريبا الان يعني قاربت على
40,000 طن من القذائف القيت على غ على غزه
وهي ا اكثر من ثمن اضعاف ما القي على
العراق في حرب ست سنوات ا وبالتالي نعم
هناك خسائر لكن السؤال لكن هل هي 30% كما
يزعم جيش الاحتلال يا سيدي السؤال او حسب
ول ستريت جورنال بالامس هل فقدت المقاومه
قدرتها على التحكم في منظومه القياده
والسيطره واداره المعركه لو كان حجم
الاضرار كبير يجب ان ينعكس على الاداء
الميداني هكذا يقول المنطق ولكن نعم تعرض
الاضرار الان في الشمال الحقت اضرار لا
ننكر لكن تم اعاده بناء القوه وتم اعاده
تشكيل ورفع جاهزيه الثمانيه كتائب في لواء
غزه ولواء الشمال وتم تعديل الاطار
الدفاعي لنطاق المسؤوليه
وتم اعاده املاء الشواغر التي استشهد
اصحابها خاصه ما نتحدث عن قاده الكتائب
الان تم احلال قاده محل القاده الذين
استشهدوا اذا نحن نتحدث عن مسار حرب لن
نتحدث عن معركه ساعه وساعتين هذا اطول حرب
تاخذها دوله الاحتلال الان وصلنا اليوم
110 في الحروب السابقه اذا استثنينا
الصراع ولا اقول القتال الصراع قبل نشوء
دوله الكيان عام 48 الاطار الزمني في هذه
المعركه تخطى مجموع كافه الحروب يعني اجمع
كافه الحروب ق تكون حروب غزه اطول حرب
كانت 51 يوم وهناك حرب 12 يوم وهناك يعني
مجموع الحروب على غزه لا يكافئ ما جرى
الان مجموع ما القي عل على غزه في تلك
الحروب لا يوازي ما القي في هذه المرحله
فيما يتعلق
بالاهداف وكان لافتا ايضا ما اشرت اليه
وذكره هارس هاليفي انه عدم وضوح الاهداف
يعني ضياع المنجزات نعم هل هل كقائد عسكري
حينما يقال له اذهب الى غزه واقضي على
حماس واتي
بالرئه الرد المنطقي في هذه الحاله هذا
ليس هدف ام هذا هدف
ضبابي الهدف له
بعدين بعد جغرافي وبعد
تنفيذ هكذا تعلمنا
وعلمنا وفي دول مختلفه تلقينا التعليم
العسكري في دول مختلفه بعقائد قتاليه
مختلفه وجميعها تتفق
عندما انت تخطط لمعركه اول شيء ما هي
الاهداف يجب بد ان تكون اهداف قابله
للتحقيق في مده محدده اهداف هي اهداف في
البدايه جغرافيه في البدايه جغرافيه ندخل
الان هذا الهدف الجغرافي وليكن منطقه
الشجاعيه على سبيل المثال يجب ان احدد حجم
القوه المدافعه عن الشجاعيه اذا اصبح لدي
بعدين الجغرافيا وال الانسان الان بناء
على على هذين البعدين انا احدد طريقه عملي
وهو ما يطلق عليه احضر ما يطلق عليه امر
العمليات الذي استوحي منه الخطه وبالتالي
هذه تحدد الي حجم القوات اللازمه وظفه
فالان ادخل في ثلاثه نقاط ومرتكزات
الامكانات الوسائل الاهداف يجب ان يكون
هناك تناسق ما بين الامكانات و ووسائل
توظيف هذا هذه الامكانات لتحقيق الهدف في
حال ضبابيه اي جزء منهم انا كقائد عسكري
لن استطيع ان اقود معركتي بالطريقه التي
انا اخطط لها وهذا ما هي الاشكاليه التي
تواجه رئيس الاركان
بانه الموقف امام ضبابي الاهداف ليست
واضحه التناقضات داخل مجلس الحرب اعضاء
مجلس الحرب يسيروا مع المظاهرات
نتنياهو يرفض قيام الدوله وزير ال التراث
يطالب بالقاء قنبله ذريه اذا الاهداف
ضبابيه فبالتالي القائد العسكري سيفشل في
تحقيق الاهداف نشكرك شكرا جزيلا اللواء
فايز الدويري الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
نشكر ايضا محمود الكن وناتي بهذا الى ختام
هذه النافذه العسكريه الخاصه بحرب اسرائيل
على غزه نعود الى غرفه الاخبار لمتابعه
اخر التطورات ليك جلال زين العابدين